steht uns menschen ein massensterben
bevor was auf den ersten blick wie
panikmache klingt ist für die forscher
dreier renommierter us-universitäten ein
extremszenario demnach steht die
menschliche rasse kurz vor dem
aussterben
vor kurzem berichteten wir infekts in
fiction auf unserer facebook seite vom
artensterben in deutschland die zahlen
waren ja da schon erschreckt forscher
dreier sehr renommierte us universitäten
haben jetzt in der fachzeitschrift
science etwas von einer drohenden welle
des massen aussterbens gesprochen bis er
seltener genannt
die menschliche rasse opfer werden aber
auch wir menschen seien mann bezeichnet
den vorgang dann als welle des
massenaussterben sven das hundertfache
an arten aus stirb als in den zeitraum
zuvor ausgestorben sind
seitdem die erde existiert arten
aufgewachsen und leben gab es bis heute
fünf derartige wellen in früheren
jahrhunderten starben von 10.000 arten
nur 2 das ist wenig im gegensatz zu den
zuständen heute die die forscher der
princeton stanford und berkeley
university herausarbeiteten
die forscher durchforsteten jede menge
daten die über das aussterben von tieren
bestehen daten die beispielsweise aus
fossilen oder ähnlichem gewonnen wurden
da die erde schon mehr als 45 millionen
jahren existiert kann man sich die
datenmenge schwer vorstellen schwer ist
es auch genau zu bestimmen was in diesen
jahren passiert ist alle daten waren
also schätzung nichtsdestotrotz konnten
vergleiche angestellt werden die
forscher verglichen die rate des
artensterbens zu einer zeit in der keine
menschen auf der erde lebten und die
aktuelle rate
demnach ist die derzeitige rate 114 mal
höher
wenn man menschen also nicht auf der
erde leben würden wäre das artensterben
114 mal geringer die menschheit hat also
ein artensterben ausgelöst dem sie
selbst zum opfer fallen wird es wäre ja
vermessen zu glauben dass wir als
einzige rasse von einem solchen
massenaussterben verschont blieben
schließlich sind wir von so vielen
lebewesen abhängig die wieder von
anderen lebewesen abhängig sind dass das
aussterben der arten auch unser
aussterben zur folge haben muss
ein immer und immer wieder genannter
grund für die vielen negativen
entwicklung auf unserem planeten an dem
wir menschen schuld sind der klimawandel
auch die umweltverschmutzung und die
brachiale rodung der wälder wurden als
ursache aufgeführt die nasa hat zu
diesen ursachen eine sehr beängstigende
animation veröffentlicht aufgenommen
wurde sich schon 2006 die aufnahmen
zeigen hochgiftige gase die über unsere
welt streifen sämtliche bewegungen von
kohlendioxid auf unserer erde werden im
farbverläufen dargestellt rot bis
violett eingefärbt flächen bezeichnen
mittlere co2 konzentration weiß und rosa
starke konzentration besonders deutlich
sieht man im sommer eine rote farbgebung
beispielsweise im norden der vereinigten
staaten
dort findet man industrieregionen warum
ist es im sommer rohde und im winter
fast schon grau im sommer können die
pflanzen noch so viel co2 verarbeiten
dass die messungen mittlere
konzentration ergeben wind ströme
verbreiten diese mittlere konzentration
dann auf viele andere länder und
kontinente die nicht so viel co2
produzieren in wirklichen teil der
erdkugel sieht man ganz helle weiße
schleier ursache waldbrände buschfeuer
und brandrodung auch diese hohe
konzentration wird dann wieder durch
winde über die ganze welt verteilt so
schnell kann die ganze welt mit
hochgiftigem gas bedeckt werden traurige
folge der daraus resultierenden klima
warum aber auch der umweltverschmutzung
und der zerstörung von lebensräumen die
weltnaturschutzunion eu cn spricht davon
dass 41 prozent aller amphibienarten und
26 prozent aller säugetierarten vom
aussterben bedroht sind
auch wenn wir menschen momentan noch
nicht direkt betroffen sind werden wir
auf jeden fall indirekt schaden nehmen
das ökosystem um uns herum wird mit
zunehmendem artensterben immer weiter
zusammenbrechen die zu wählen und
dürreperioden werden uns nach und nach
das leben schwer machen und wenn uns das
klima keine probleme bereitet dann das
artensterben der tierarten wer bestimmt
noch unsere blumen oder bäume wenn die
bienenvölker aussterben was passiert mit
dem natürlichen zyklus der tierwelt die
welt des vernetzt reist das netz an
einer stelle ein kann das zur
kettenreaktion führen und mit so vielen
löchern im netz die jetzt entstehen sind
zahllose kettenreaktionen wahrscheinlich
wenn die sechste welle das
massenaussterben es eintrifft werden wir
menschen wohl richtig zu spüren bekommen
wie sehr wir doch von alldem um uns
herum abhängig sind einer der forscher
aus den usa paul ehrlich von der
stanford university meint dass es keinen
relevanten zweifel gebe dass uns eine
sechste welle bevor steht eine der
ursachen des massen aussterbens und der
dramatischen umweltverschmutzung ist
unser fleischkonsum wie schädlich der
ist könnte in diesem video sehen zu rap
und zum block kommt ihr hier unten und
was glaubt ihr muss passieren damit die
menschen endlich den umgang mit ihrem
lebensraum ändern muss es tatsächlich zu
einem katastrophenszenario com
diskutiertes in den kommentaren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran